cet amendement donc
vise à instituer une contribution
exceptionnelle de solidarité sur les
super profits il vise les entreprises
dans le bénéfice net aurait été en 2021
supérieure de 20% à la moyenne des trois
années 2017 2018 et 2019 qui se
verraient ainsi appliquer une
contribution à hauteur de 20 % calculée
sur la différence entre les deux
montants comme je le dis en discussion
générale en 2020 on n'a pas hésité à
mettre en place une contribution
exceptionnelle sur les complémentaires
santé à hauteur d'un milliard cinq ça
n'a pas fait débat ensuite au cours de
la crise qu vide nous avons voté tous
les soutiens aux entreprises je rappelle
par exemple un prêt garanti par l'état
d'un milliard à cma-cgm on a voté les
reports de charge tous les différents
dispositifs
on était en soutien des entreprises
quelles que soient leurs difficultés on
a été capable de voter des soutiens
exceptionnels il semble aujourd'hui
qu'on peut espérer une contribution
exceptionnelle parce que elle est unique
elle est borné dans le temps enfin je
rappelle que tous les pays voisins le
met en place l'espagne l'italie la
roumanie la grèce le royaume uni et
l'allemagne réfléchit et je n'ai pas
l'impression qu'on pourrait être les
seuls à avoir raison de ne pas y penser
merci
[Musique]